＼ﾄﾞﾝｯ／
よしっ
おぉし！
＼ﾊﾟｧﾝ／
皆さんにはこれが何に見えるか？
人はこれをお風呂と言うかもしれない
いつから人はこれをお風呂と言うようになったか？
簡単な話です。
みんなが普段入るお風呂と言う存在概念は、
この形という固定概念に
囚われてしまっているから、
みんなはこれをお風呂と言う。
だが私は違う！
私はこれをお風呂という固定概念で見ることなく、
もっと広い視野で見たとき、
お風呂の固定概念を取っぱらって考えて見てください！
これはどう見ても
大きなお皿です！
はい、というわけで新品のお風呂...
お皿を買いました。
キレイな状況なので、
僕はこれはもうお風呂じゃありません！
お皿として見ています！
この前提で、
いくよ？
はい、というわけで
もう、すぐ！
静岡を去ることになります。
最後にね、もう静岡でみんなでデカイことしようかなと思って
みんなで...
カレーパーティーしてぇなって思ったんですよ！
大きなお皿にカレーをいっぱい盛って
みんなで食べようと思ったんですけども
思った瞬間僕はもう
というわけで静岡の給食センターから
ご飯、カレーライス！
たっくさん準備してもらったぞォ
というわけで今日は、
お風呂！
否！！
この大きなお皿いっぱいにカレーを盛って、
みんなで食べていきたいと、思います！
とりあえずみんな勘違いしないで欲しいのは
一回ももうお風呂として使っていません！
新品を買いました。
そしてキレイです！
もう食器だと思ってることを
勘違いしないでいただきたいから、
家のお風呂でやっちゃ、ダメだぞ？
では行こう！
では早速、カレーをよそっていきまーす
あ〜懐かしい...
あっつい！！
たくみ(?)：わぁすげぇ給食っぽいな〜
たくみ(?)：わーヤベェェ！
はじめ：待って待って待ってwww
はじめ：このままドスンって行けばいいんだよね？w
はじめ：こんな給食当番いたか今まで
はじめ：あぁ〜でも多いなぁ〜
はじめ：こうやって混ぜないとね。
はじめ：怒られる。
たくみ：うん、下が濃くなる。
よし、カレーいきます。
ﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃｹﾃﾝ♪
はい、出来ました〜！
はい！
というわけで！
今日の、
給食の、
準備ができたので、
みんなを、
呼びます！
みんなしゅうごぉおおおう！！！
はじめ：食べよう！！
はじめ：給食の時間だよ！
まさき：え、でも美味しそうなんだけど。
はじめ：給食センターのやつだよ。
まさき：まじで！？
まさき：給食食べられるってこと？
はじめ：はい！、はい！
はじめ：よし、給食の時間だァ！
たくみ：っしゃあ！　まさき：イエイ！
はじめ；あ、ちなみに...
wwwwww
まさき：いけるんじゃね？
はじめ：いやいけるで正直
はじめ；あざますっ
はじめ：あの女の子たちの分も食わなきゃいけないんだよ
はじめ：苦しそうに食ってた女の子たちの分
まさき：うふふふww
はじめ：じゃあ、いただきますか！
はじめ：いただきまーす！
たくみ＆まさき：いただきまーす
はじめ：まずは、味がね...
はじめ：うめえうめえうめぇ！
はじめ：美味い！美味い！
はじめ：余裕でしょこれは
まさき：いけるいける！
はじめ：事前に二人には、
はじめ：あんまり食べないようにって言ってきてあるんで
はじめ：いけるでしょ！
はじめ：あ、結構深いな。
wwwwww
はじめ：浅いように見えますけど、
はじめ：結構ありますからね！
はじめ：だいちくーーーーん！！
はじめ：だいちくんカレー食べよ？
だいちくん：もう無くなった？
はじめ：ほとんど食べたよ。
だいちくん：たいして変わってないやん
はじめ：というわけでちょっと3人だと間違いなく無理だったので、
はじめ：ちょっとずつ人を増やしていきます！
＼ｶｼｬ／
はじめ：これ痛い？痛いの？
はじめ：給食な...
はじめ；でもさすごいよね給食って。
ははははwww
はじめ：すごいよ？だって
はじめ：こんな...だって、
はじめ：絶対男の子と食べなさそうな~
はじめ：女の子とか〜...
はじめ：と、食べれるんだよ？
だいちくん：確かに。
たくみ：確かに。
はじめ：すごいよ？だって....
はじめ：高校からもう、無理なんだよ？
はじめ：高校から女の子と食べれない！ご飯が。
はじめ：お疲れい！！
まさき：お疲れー！
たくみ：お疲れぃ！
まさき：はい。
？？？：あぁ、ありがとうございます。
まさき：嬉しいでしょ？
はじめ：お疲れーーー！
まさき＆たくみ：お疲れーー！！
まさき：みんな待ち望んでたからね
はじめ：どうぞどうぞ。
はじめ：カレーですどうぞーー！！
たくみ：おめでとーー！！
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
？？？：ありがとうございます。
はっはっはっはっはっ
たくみ：えー待ってそこ見えてきた、そこ。
はじめ：もう結構終盤じゃないですかこれは
？？？：きたよ〜
はじめ：うん、減ってる！
はじめ：完全に減ってる。
？？？：最高。
はじめ；7人でいけば流石に、減るね。
たくみ：減るねぇ。
たくみ：うち1人3人前、ちょいでしょ？
はじめ：7×4...28...
wwwwwwww
全然、計算...#@$%&...www
＼ﾋﾟｰﾝﾎﾟｰｰﾝ／
おおぉっっ！！！
まさき：はあああ！
はじめ：お疲れーーー！！
たくみ：待ってたよ！！
はじめ：ご飯食べた？
？？？：いや、ちょっと食べました。
はじめ：よし！
おめでとーー！
ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ
はじめ：もうだって...
はじめ：もう16時だよ？
たくみ：やばいな。
たくみ：もう夜ご飯じゃん！
？？？：ほんとだ。
たくみ：さっきまで....
たくみ：オシャレな朝ご飯というお昼ご飯のもんなご（？）
たくみ：とか、言ってるやついたのにww
？？？：あとどんぐらいっすかー？
？？？：もうこれ終わったら、一回....
＼ｺﾞﾄｯｯ／
＼ｶﾞｼｬｰﾝ／
うわあああ！
え、え、え、おぁー
おっとおっと、おっおっ
おぉおぉおぉっ？
はじめ：みんな落ち着いて〜
はじめ：皿の破片が危ないから落ち着いて〜
はじめ：先生なんとかするから！
はじめ：みんな落ち着いて〜
はじめ：っしゃあー！！
はじめ：よし...食べたか！
もう食えねぇ。
はじめ：せ〜の、
みんな：ごちそうさまでしたっ